all right joe podcast sean warned me to
give you a warning
i think because he was planning on
listening to this episode with his
youngest daughter who's 17 and
he hasn't told her about santa claus yet
so
if you haven't had the santa claus
discussion with your kids
you may want to listen to this episode
without them we're going to be talking
about christmas and gift giving and a
bunch of things
including santa claus enjoy the episode
this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today we're going to talk
about celebrating the holiday
season with purpose and intention and of
course
well we have uh meg here uh she wrote
this book
minimalist christmas and we'll be
talking a lot about christmas today it's
january
i'm sorry it's december 1st the the day
this comes out
and so uh meg i i
i can't tell you how many questions
we get about gift giving and ryan i
often talk about our own approach and
we'll be talking about that a bit today
but i'm really
excited because you wrote an entire book
with your approach and so we'll put a
link to your book in
the show notes as well but why is gift
giving such a a fro
topic oh gosh it's part of culture
it's part of expectations and we've
built an entire holiday around it and
this
consumer consumer's holiday almost feels
like a religion
in itself and so we really
truly believe we have to give other
people
gifts right and when you become a
minimalist or
try to simplify your life even just a
smidgen
now you have this tug and pool about
well do i
give these people these gifts and now
give them
a little extra stress or take a little
bit more of their time away even though
i've done everything i can to declutter
my own house after watching
uh you know tidying up on netflix and
i've thrown everything away but now i
know everything's coming back in
uh it's it's a hard time for anyone
trying to simplify and so the whole
reason why i wrote it
was because i'm in all of these
minimalist groups on facebook
and for years and years now i've become
a little annoyed by the same
10 questions over and over and over
again to the point where this last fall
i almost muted all of my facebook groups
oh wow
and then it occurred to me that there's
not a book particularly on these pain
points yeah
actually kind of copy the book i want to
hold it up for for youtube because i
have i have an advanced copy here
there we go so my child colored on this
one
oh that's even better so uh the book is
minimalist christmas have yourself a
minimalist christmas
and um that's what we're talking about
today ryan i
thought it was fascinating that whenever
i think about this topic
i think about the holiday season i think
about
joy and cheer
togetherness togetherness yeah family
contribution yeah and
and but what i actually think about when
i really think about it
stress overwhelm anxiety debt
oh debt yeah discontent worry
shame uh the most joyous time of the
year
the holiday season has been turned into
the holiday
shopping season and now that it's
december and
folks are listening to this and it's
obviously a different year from years
past
but it doesn't mean we're shopping less
we've just moved our shopping online
so meg talk to me about some of the
questions we have some audience
questions here
but of those 10 questions you get all
the time uh so to speak here i'll get
this back to you
uh of those 10 questions what um
what comes up the most and what what
which question do you actually enjoy
answering the most the biggest question
is how do i get my
mother-in-law the grandmother the aunt
the best friend there's some chronic
gift giver in everyone's life i have
this problem that is the source of the
most of the the influx of things
in their homes especially during the
holidays or for birthdays
and the biggest pain point is how do i
ask that person
to give less or to not give anything how
do i get them
on board with minimalism right and so
that that's the biggest source of angst
yeah
trying to simplify and and so i have
someone in my family who likes to give
our daughter a lot of stuff even though
we've set good expectations
and because we've done a really good job
setting good expectations
rarely do we get access stuff we often
get the things
that she needs or they'll ask us or the
gift experiences and we'll talk about
all those things today
but i have this one person in particular
who
from time to time sort of oversteps that
bound that we've
we've set so what what advice do you
have for someone like me
who has a seven-year-old daughter and
i don't want to deprive her obviously
but also i don't want her to think that
stuff equals happiness exactly
it really starts further in advance
it may be even a little too late by the
time this podcast comes out
but really kind of approach this from
here on out for the next year
to start having conversations with the
the avid
gift giver yeah about all the pain
points
that excess stuff in your house is
giving you that
you're spending so much time constantly
picking up toys
and the kids can't get out the door fast
enough for school
we can't find shoes because we have 25
pairs of shoes
we you know and you have given me 20 of
them don't say that
um so if you talk about these pain
points of the overwhelm you don't have
to use the word minimalism because that
can be a scary word to these people who
find a lot of joy in the dopamine rush
of obtaining items even we're kind of
screwed ryan we've already
labeled ourselves the minimalist right
they already think we're weird that's
right
the whole families are like yeah i'm not
really sure about this whole minimalism
thing how's that going to work out for
you
yeah it happens to be working out yeah
so so meg i love what you're talking
about here with with the pain points i
think that makes a lot of sense yeah
then you have to talk about um what has
helped
so you you set it all up and then in
another casual conversation as things
come up
then you talk about like oh my gosh you
know we only have one
plate per person in the house and i
don't have to spend the whole night
washing dishes anymore i don't even run
the dishwasher
anymore it is really yeah you just
really talk about the benefits you don't
have to use any scary words
you don't have to say decluttering you
don't have to say minimalism yeah but
you can just talk about these things
that they slowly come on board this
might be a years long
process and then you have to set
realistic expectations that
some people will just never get it
because they are so addicted
to that dopamine and oxytocin chemical
cocktail boost that they get in their
brain and so you just have to
come at it with grace and say thank you
and then have no guilt when you let go
of those things
no i i love the approach uh especially
use the word grace because when you're
explaining to someone that you don't
want their gifts it sounds very mean to
be like hey
we don't want your gifts uh the
conversation that you're talking about
having with someone like that it's
it's it's exactly what you need to do
it's uh
it's showing them uh the pain that you
experience
uh getting the gifts the joy you have
living a clutter-free life
um the one thing you know i will say is
when i have to have these tough
conversations with people
i tend to say the word i when it's
something negative
i am overwhelmed by too much stuff i
feel like i've had too much stuff in my
life i feel
uh you know uh like when when i have
my toys or my kids toy chest overflowing
i feel a lot of stress
and then anytime you say something
positive you use the word
you like you're such a good
mother-in-law that i know that you're
gonna help me with this
but a lot of the times and i used to you
know be guilty of this
you know you look at someone i did this
with my mom which is not the right way
to
to go about it but i'm like you get me
too much stuff you don't respect me
you you you you blaming naming yeah and
all that does is make it worse so
i think the the word grace there is very
important when you're having these
conversations with people exactly
just always staying in a frame of of
gratitude
because they're not trying to sabotage
you so many of these people that
that i saw writing questions in
minimalist facebook groups
they looked at it like this person is
trying to sabotage
all of my efforts like it was
mean-spirited and on purpose but really
the you know i know you have a different
take on love languages but
for that person from the way that they
have been conditioned by society
sure they are trying to express love and
care and
they want to contribute to your
household help out with maybe finances
by
giving you something they they think you
need or will like
so so to accept that with some grace and
gratitude
and let them have that rush that they're
getting in their brain
and don't take away that moment because
they're experiencing joy
for christmas yeah by seeing that and so
you can say thank you
in that moment and give them the hug but
you don't have to hold on to it forever
you don't have to hold on to it for the
next week once they give it to you
it's yours exactly do with whatever you
want you are in charge of what is
allowed to
step foot into your house absolutely
beautiful let's hop into some of these
audience questions here we've got a
question from jordan in akron ohio
how do you get through the holidays when
you're surrounded in a work environment
that
literally thrives off of consumerism and
retail you know i'm a i work at a salon
my boyfriend works in retail he's
manager
and the holidays just really seem to
drain us because of the months of
preparation
and with me trying to take up like this
new lifestyle
i'm just wondering like how can we
continue
to like have this mentality in this
mantra
while our work environment is also like
draining
us because of all this consumerism and
all
this months of preparation it's just a
lot and i
i find a lot of the times we're so
drained from it so jordan
you know if i were to rephrase your
question i would just say how do i
mentally manage the holiday season when
i work in an industry that is dependent
on
consumerism and
ryan and i aren't actually against you
may think we are because we're the
minimalists and meg i assume you
probably have a similar take on this but
we're not against retail stores in fact
ryan i own a coffee shop that's
technically a
retail store right in fact ryan and i
worked in
retail and there was a certain level of
discontent about 40
of our business was done in the last two
months of the year
and so the in fact we planned for 11
months for the holiday shopping
season right exactly black friday door
buster sales the
the whole holiday season and
what what troubled me about that wasn't
the fact that we were selling
products or services i'm fine with that
if those products or services add
value to people's lives but creating a
false demand
a false sense of urgency uh
creates a lot of discontent in people
and i noticed that that is what we were
doing
and so while retail isn't against my
values the particular retail
establishment for which ryan and i
worked
was against our values and we had to
come up with a plan to eventually walk
away from that
to untether ourselves from that
lifestyle
it doesn't mean that jordan you can't
you and your boyfriend can't go
somewhere else and work for a different
retail store maybe even a different
salon you said you work in a salon
a salon that is obsessed with
consumerism might be one type of salon
but there are
other salons out there who are
interested in adding value to a client
base and then being compensated
accordingly
meg what are your thoughts on on someone
who's working in industry
that encourages consumerism
i might come at it with curiosity and be
grateful for the experience to get to
witness this firsthand i also used to
work in retail
especially for a holiday when i was in
college i worked for
a fashion brand and i would do
thanksgiving whenever i came home for
thanksgiving holidays and then i would
show back up for christmas
and stay through the new year and so i
got to go through the whole black friday
and see the day after christmas the week
after christmas
all of the returns i mean lines out the
door
way more than the christmas shopping was
was the returns
yeah in exchanges for things that they
actually wanted
and so i'm grateful for that experience
to be able to see firsthand
i also worked in digital marketing for a
lot of companies
and so i'm grateful for the experience
to see how you can
target consumers online and how those
analytics work
and how you can chase people all around
and find similar people with similar
interests and backgrounds and shopping
habits
and it opened my eyes and helped me
reign in my own shopping
and my own consumerism and help me with
my minimalist practice
because i can see kind of what's
happening behind the scenes
so maybe look at it through the lens of
curiosity
and just study it and let that
strengthen your own minimalism
can i ask you a question about that
because um
i agree with that but it seems to me
jordan feels like and maybe i'm i'm
projecting this onto her but maybe she
feels like she's part of the problem and
no longer wants to be part of the
problem did you ever feel
as you as your curiosity sort of came to
its end
and and you had satiated that that that
need to
understand the consumer habits of other
people did you start to feel like oh wow
what i'm doing
might actually be part of the problem
yes
trying to think i mean you can always
change directions i'm trying to figure
that out
myself right now with this book of how
to go about
selling a product when i'm a minimalist
that has a whole book that's talking
about almost
like anti-consumerism and being aware
of big data big business
data tracking and how do i do this
without using my own knowledge of these
things
yeah so um how do you
step out of the retail space and find
something that more aligns with your own
values
yeah well what's fascinating about what
she's saying ryan is
that well
we often conflate consumerism with
consumption and so
ryan and i sell products and services
that we believe in
right now i would feel a certain amount
of discontent if like ryan and i
just sold a book that we didn't like or
didn't believe in or
hastily put together and felt like it
wasn't really going to add value to
people's lives or if we were doing
something that was a cash grab
but at the same time not against making
money i mean in fact that's
just what we do in our society if we can
add more value to someone's life then
we're able to charge a premium for that
product or service and
i don't think there's a problem with
that i think the problem
lies in the way that we market
those things to people and what i can
tell with what you're doing meg is
you wrote a book because people were
asking a question there was a pent-up
demand
about this and so what you're doing is
simply providing a solution
to a problem a pre-existing problem and
to me that's what
you know we often say good businesses
make money
great businesses make a difference i
would say the same thing about books and
i think what you're trying to do here is
is make a difference with that book and
i'm proud of you for putting it out
there i think whatever we do in life
like there's always got to be a little
bit of cognitive dissonance
with what the reality is it's like you
know uh
we use macs we have apple products
um we really have to like not pretend
or we have to pretend that apple is not
making these products in an
unsustainable way
paying people cheaply i mean there's
always there's always something there's
an angle
i feel like i could personally always
find that's going to make me feel guilty
for what i do
and i don't know the appropriate balance
with cognitive dissonance but with
jordan here
you know i i don't want to like guilt
and shame her and her boyfriend for
working in retail
uh because they it's not their job to
tell someone what they should and
shouldn't want
uh i mean they're they're in the service
industry so their job is to be a good
uh customer service uh person so
um yeah i mean if it's if you're waking
up
and you're feeling guilty every single
day like that is a symptom
that maybe you should start to look for
something else but
i don't feel like you know i'm i'm not
going to look at jordan and her
boyfriend and be like
sorry you guys are not gonna get your
minimalist certificates because you work
in retail
um i mean that's that's not uh that's
not what josh and i's job to do uh
is it's just to give you our perspective
on it and personally if i was in a spot
where i needed to make the money
if i quit my job i wouldn't be able to
pay my bills like i
i would still be able to get up go to
work but yeah i would certainly
maybe start to look for something a
little bit different but uh
yeah just don't beat yourselves up too
much but yeah form a plan to maybe go
into
a different different industry but yeah
at the end of the day like josh and i
are not here
to say what people should and shouldn't
own it's that's up to
individuals to decide that jordan i'm
gonna send you a copy of
meg's book it's called have yourself a
minimalist christmas we're also gonna
put a link to it in the show notes so
folks can check it out
if you'd like our next question is from
shelby in memphis tennessee
how can i incorporate uh minimalism into
this and every other holiday while
having children
especially the ones that seem to be only
about receiving presents
i don't want my child to feel like
they're missing out or that santa favors
other children
that don't want to be a part of the
culture that just blindly consumes
just to consume so how can i foster
these great childhood memories for my
daughter while not straying from
minimalism
all right shelby so how do you not be
scrooge mcduck yeah how do you not be
the grinch oh wait mcduck is uh
he swam through he he swam through money
that's not who i'm thinking of i'm just
thinking of scrooge in general right
yeah how do you not be a scrooge uh
because here's the thing i
i agree with this and i think about this
too we don't want to deprive
our children of the holidays and
unfortunately we think it's binary
right meg it's like well you know what
um it's
either splurge and it's 400 presents
under the tree
or it's ba humbug yeah here is
your you know avocado or whatever have a
nice christmas
um obviously it doesn't have to be that
way i want to talk to you about a couple
rules
that ryan and i have in a moment that i
think are helpful but i'd love to hear
your uh your take first yes another huge
question
that i heard a lot and that i struggled
with too
i talked about in the book how i became
a minimalist and i was such a good
minimalist all year
decluttered all these things was feeling
really good with getting my time back
i wasn't spending very much money on
silly things
and then christmas came it was my first
child's
first christmas and i got her everything
she could ever need for the next five
years of her life i mean
a one-year-old and she had a three-story
dollhouse and the rocking horse and the
antique wicker pram
and all these big things and then all
the big things were stuffed with all the
little things and i
i had no budget set for myself
i was just so excited to play santa
and if you have any children in the
background you might want to
scoot them out but um i'm not anti-santa
at all
i love the magic of it i remember as a
kid going to bed
i had a tradition with my two younger
sisters where we always slept in the
same bed together
one time a year we've even done it as
adults
yeah exactly i love that because we
would lay in bed gosh what do you think
santa's gonna bring
oh my gosh i don't know maybe it'll be
this one thing and uh oh do you
did you hear something was that a bump
on the roof oh my gosh we gotta go to
sleep or else he won't give us anything
so you know there's magic in it you set
out the cookies and you set out the
milk and i don't want to take that away
from any child
yeah but they don't have to wake up to
the living room
overflowing with things and so
you can set up expectations in advance
maybe not this year but you could start
it next year i
actually recommend coming up with a
story where if you want to try the four
gift rule
which many minimalists subscribe to
which is the
something you want something you need
something to wear something to read
you can say that that's coming from
santa you know these are the four things
you know the elves can't
make 500 toys for every child in the
world
but santa can bring you four things and
you can go by these guidelines which
i really like because there's only one
want
and all the other things are more like
needs kind of functional yeah yeah
so to kind of start a child thinking in
that way and if there are extra things
they can come from some parents or they
can come from aunts and
grandmothers and so that's fine but
you can try that approach if you're used
to giving 200 things and four sounds
insane then change the rhyme to two
things you want
two things you need you know yeah um you
can set a budget for yourself
most americans spend a thousand dollars
per person
which is insane to me yeah so you can
set
i wonder how much per person uh they're
going into debt yeah oh i know almost
all of it
yeah we're already in debt and so the
thing is if the average indebted
household has sixteen thousand dollars
in credit card debt
uh that's the indebted households then
then
you have to think you're already in debt
and so by not allocating that thousand
dollars toward your debt you're
effectively going into debt even if
you're not adding more on to your debt
because that you're taking money away
that you could be using to pay off your
debt
the the santa claus thing is is
something fascinating i
and we're going to talk about it on the
maximal episode i think you and i differ
a bit on the santa claus thing although
we we do have fun around the whole santa
claus myth
with with our daughter so i wouldn't
focus on the santa claus
so much so i used to take the approach
of
what do you want santa to bring let's
talk about santa all month long
we're gonna go visit santa tell him
every single thing that
every whim and desire you've ever wanted
you know and instead
put the focus more on traditions yeah
yeah we'll get more into that
on the maximal for sure ryan what do you
got for shelby
oh i you know i love the idea of having
the rules i mean that makes me think
about how josh and i
we get asked a lot like you know what do
i do with you know when i have kids and
i want to be a minimalist
um with what we basically suggest is
like hey look as
parents you get to set boundaries up
with your kids and maybe you can go to
your children
and help have them help you set those
boundaries
so yeah they could suggest like hey
we're thinking about getting every
kid four gifts you know and the the what
is it something you
want something you need something to
wear something to read so
if uh if that's appropriate and and your
child feels good about it great like
that's that's the expectation that
uh you know you're setting up together
and that's really what matters
um it's interesting though a couple
things uh
kids it's almost like they have this
power of making you feel
guilty for like not being the parent
that you know
they feel like you should be and then i
can only imagine with shelby here
there's guilt of like oh you know they
think i'm a bad parent i don't want to
be a bad parent
but you know being a good parent is
setting up those
boundaries the other thing too is shelby
if you're showing
your children love the whole year like
if if you're really going out of your
way
to love your kids to make them feel
loved yeah i promise you like it doesn't
matter
how many gifts you give them they're
going to feel loved i
i have seen a lot where you know certain
parents are working all the time maybe
they don't
uh they're not able to show as much love
as they want to because they're working
or whatever they're doing so then they
try to make up for it
with all these gifts during the holidays
and
that's i'm not judging anyone who's
doing this but that's probably the worst
way
to like show someone love is to just buy
them a bunch of gifts it's not very
thoughtful and then oh by the way if you
don't buy them the right gifts then
you're not showing them the right
amount of love or the right kind of love
and it that could create its own
problem so yeah focus on loving your
kids and showing them love going
out of your way every day to show them
love throughout the year and no matter
what you do for christmas like they're
going to be appreciative they're going
to feel loved
what if you fed your kids only on
holidays
right right you you'd feel like a bad
parent yeah yeah
and you know for me i don't think gift
giving is a love language any more than
pig latin is a romance
language however i think the real love
language here what we're trying to do
when we give a gift some
to someone is we're trying to add value
to our life we're trying to contribute
beyond
ourselves we're trying to contribute to
the people we love that is the love
language
i just wouldn't confuse gift giving with
love gift giving is a transaction
and love is not transactional love is
transcendent
and and so i think we need to make that
distinction so shelby two rules
for you in fact we're gonna send you a
copy of the minimalist rule book
it's free for anyone who wants to
download it the minimalists.com slash
rule book there's 16 rules for living
with less in there
and two of those have to do with gifts
one is the minimalist
gift giving rule and the other
surprisingly
is the minimalist gift getting rule we
often don't think about
the the getting of gifts in fact we have
a question coming up we're gonna be
talking about that a little bit but
anyone can download that
rulebook for free the minimalists.com
slash
rule book or if you want the audiobook
version ryan and i came into the studio
we recorded an audio book we did a mini
podcast about each
individual rule talked about what we
like to get as gifts and
and give as gifts as well but those two
rules will help you out because
it helps you see past the normal
materialistic items of gift giving
it shows you how you can give better
gifts and also how you can ask
for better gifts as a minimalist ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it is time for our lightning round where
we answer your text messages you can
text your questions and comments to
area code 937-202
yes indeed meg these texts go to both
ryan's and my phones and we respond to a
lot of people we even respond to a few
people here on
the podcast now during the lightning
round so ryan and i and our guest
we do our best to answer every question
with a short shareable less than 140
character response
and we put the text to these minimal
maxims in the show notes so people can
copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if they'd like but
really we just yammer on a bit
until we get something pithy or at least
podcast sean gets something pithy
we have a question here from alan how do
we tactfully ask
loved ones not to give us gifts
especially those who grew up
with gift giving as a practice to show
appreciation for others
well here's a i have a pithy answer i'm
curious what you would say about this
meg this is really the core of the
minimalist
gift getting rule and i just
summed it up in a tweetable phrase don't
practice saying
no practice saying yes to what matters
i think too often we get caught up in
that in this this position i i know i do
when especially when someone's giving my
daughter these things i don't want them
to give
i always want to say no stop but
let me step back for a second and say
well what are they trying to accomplish
here
clearly they love me they're trying to
add value to my life
right and what am i saying no stop
loving me stop adding value to my life
well instead of saying that maybe i
should figure out a better way to
communicate what
would add value to my life if you're
getting me a pair of cufflinks or a
necktie
then it could just be that you didn't
know that those things wouldn't add
value to my life i should probably do a
better job setting expectations
exactly what do you think oh i
completely agree
it could either be in a broad sense of
making sure they understand your values
for example we're really trying to cut
down our on the amount of plastic
we bring in the house we don't want to
continue voting with our dollars for
more plastic items and contributing to
landfills where it lasts for thousands
upon thousands of years and
goes into our air and water so i've been
trying to subtly get that across to
family members
to maybe shift their focus to more
wooden or glass or stainless steel if
they really want to
just find a better sustainable option
for the item that they think
will add value to our life the other
thing i suggest
i i'm as a woman i love pinterest
i do i get sucked into the vortex and i
love the organization of everything
i love that is your pinterest handle for
folks listening it's a
i should be meg nordman okay yeah and uh
yeah i have tons of minimalist christmas
boards oh great let's put a link to uh
awesome meg's pinterest in the show
notes sean
great um yeah so i think if you organize
a pinterest board
as a wish list that way you can have
links
from everywhere you know you could make
a target
wish list or an amazon wishlist but then
you're confined to one
single source so i like pinterest for
that
reason because it can be pinned from any
website so i do like to send
one board to all the grandmoms and all
the
ants and say if you're interested in
getting something for the girls
this year these are some of the items i
was looking at and
those items will be little wooden toys
or
certain children's books on topics that
i think they would find interesting
so that's one way because it gives them
the ability
to be intentional now ryan you and i did
we
did a minimalist weddings uh episode
and uh in in doing that um
we exposed that during you and i both
had weddings uh for our first marriages
and we exposed that a lot of the gifts
we got were
rather unintentional somehow i
ended up with three bread makers now i
don't eat bread so that's a bad gift in
general but three
is especially bad now part of that was
bad because
i probably didn't do a good enough job
setting expectations
but two is think about what we're doing
here
we're creating obligation and these
obligatory gift-giving days
it actually takes all of the intention
out of the holiday season and so
when we do something like what you're
doing with the pinterest board
you're you're injecting intention into
it you're allowing people to be more
deliberate
you feel better about it they feel
better about it
it's a win-win for everyone yeah
yeah i mean really what meg's talking
about here is
showing uh the gifts that she say she
can say yes to
and uh it goes right in line with what
you were saying um so let's say
that you set these expectations you send
out the list and people still like you
said
uh earlier in the podcast people are
still gonna like maybe overstep those
boundaries
might pit the answer is this receiving
love is more important than receiving
gifts
so when someone does overstep their
boundaries eat or overstep your
boundaries even though you've laid them
out clearly
you've told them what you can say yes to
and they still
just want to show you love by getting
you something like you said earlier
receive that tell them okay great i
appreciate the love that you're trying
to give me give them a hug
um but you know there's really there are
certain family members who they're not
they're going to do what they want to do
rather than what you want to do and i
think you still need to have those tough
conversations have them with grace
but ultimately the the goal is is to
receive the love that
your friend or family member is trying
to give you exactly
and to me the goal is togetherness for
the holidays
so i have a chapter called presence over
presence
you know yeah and so just be present
with them don't
let your face get all red hot when you
realize that a giant
plastic playset is now in your living
room
right you know let the kids have a blast
on it
for the next couple of days while
they're there in town
you know maybe you haven't seen them in
months because of the pandemic
or because they live 12 hours away so
just accept it with grace and gratitude
and be present with the kids
present with the family members and then
you know
when you do your spring cleaning and you
take down the decorations you can do
your post christmas decluttering
right you could find whatever it is a
really good home but you know i want to
i want to differentiate
what i'm what we're saying here we what
we are saying is
to appreciate the love to appreciate the
act it doesn't mean that you have to
appreciate the item that they gave you
but you can
certainly appreciate the intention that
they were that they're that they have
for your
for your christmas yeah let me just wrap
up with something practical here and
this is from the minimalist gift giving
rule in the minimalist rule book
um since you mentioned presence is the
best present there's sort of a section
there where we talk about
so what if you decided to gift only
experiences
this year as an experiment right how
much more memorable would your holidays
be consider these experiences concert
tickets a home-cooked meal
tickets to a play or a musical breakfast
in bed a back rub we did this reason
i bought uh you know my friend you
haven't given me a back rub in so long
it's been weeks uh and
uh no right
uh you know our friend randy randy k
who's been on this podcast um
she is a massage therapist so i asked
her
i surprised bex with this um i asked
randy like what massage table
should we get so we have a massage table
at home now and of course
because of the 90 90 rule i have to use
it regularly right
and which is a great excuse to get a
back rubber to give a back rub
and um it was as long as it's something
that we use
it was a wonderful family gift basically
that bex and i
it's a gift that they say the gift that
keeps on giving because we
as long as we continue to use it we both
get value from and it's like
constantly giving a gift so i i like
that as a sort of
experience of course you don't need a
massage table in order to give someone
a back rub a foot rub a full body
massage a holiday parade walking or
driving somewhere without a plan
spending an evening talking with no
distractions making out under the
mistletoe
visiting a festival of lights we try to
do this with
with ella several times a year we'll
even take her like we'll take her to
rodeo drive
and she doesn't even know that there's
it's a shopping destination because we
take her there during christmas and
ryan's gone with us before
and just a bunch of beautiful palm trees
with lights all around them yeah and
because
it's so beautiful she doesn't realize
those retail stores there
i'm sure she will when she gets older
but right now it's just like oh
everyone's here to look at the lights
right
yeah they don't know that they're going
to louis vuitton or whatever we don't
take her in there
watching a sunrise skiing snowboarding
sledding dancing taking your children to
a petting zoo
making snow angels preparing a batch of
hot apple cider
taking a vacation together watching a
sunset what other experiences can you
give
don't you think you'd find more value in
these experiences than material gifts
don't you think your loved ones
would ultimately find more value too and
if you must present an experience in a
physical manner
print it in a on a full color thick
piece of paper and wrap it in a with an
ornate bow and and ribbons
and in a box and gift wrap it uh to add
a material element to the adventure i
think that's one of the things we get
really excited about
giving a physical gift right but you can
gift the the experiences
one of my favorite things it's gone
viral almost every year
for a reason for probably the past five
plus years there's a grandmother
who created she got a shoe box and she
decorated it and inside the shoe box
is 12 envelopes that fit perfectly and
each envelope is labeled you know
december january february march
every single month and each envelope is
decorated she took the time to put
little stickers and pom-poms and
doodles on them very deliberately and
then inside
were things like here's a gift card to
go play put putt golf together
you know with grand mom and here is
uh we're going to go to this little cafe
together for ice cream and so she
pre-set up the whole year
for experiences and togetherness
presence
and it came in an adorable box and they
can't open the envelopes until
the first of each month to see what
they're going to get to do with grandmom
so they get the gift of anticipation as
well
which is so much more powerful for kids
i found whenever they love christmas yes
it's the whole month of
what's going to happen on that day right
it's not really the stuff
it's just the anticipation of a magical
being showing up on your rooftop
yeah yeah we got so much more to talk
about we've got some listener tips
coming up we got our added value segment
but it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like what
are seven
seven different ways to decorate for
christmas like a minimalist
how do i let go of gifts without
offending the givers
what will joshua and ryan's christmases
look like this year
how do i politely decline invitations
for holiday parties at work
and how do i tactfully explain to my
children that there
is no santa claus plus a million more
questions about gift giving
for meg and the minimalists if you want
to hear all that subscribe to our
maximal episodes on the minimalist
private podcast it's a completely
separate podcast
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income because
you know we don't believe in
advertisements by the way if you're not
a private podcast subscriber you're
literally missing two-thirds of our show
plus hundreds of hours of past previous
uh private podcast episodes so try it
out for a week or a month it's cheaper
than a cup of coffee head on over to the
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app ryan what you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hi josh and ryan this is laura calling
from kansas city missouri
there's a book called i think you're
wrong but i'm listening
by sarah holland who's a democrat and
best silvers who's a republican
they have a lot of tips and insight on
how to have kind and respectful
political discussions with people
that we love but disagree with they also
have a podcast called pantsuit politics
where they practice what they preach in
their books
this is caitlin from salt lake city utah
i just listened to your episode on books
and thought i might give a tip for
others that really helped me a few
months ago
when i reduced my book collection from
about 400
to 100 books about a third of which i
have to use for work anyway
and what i realized was that the reason
i did not want to let go of my books
was because i perceived value in them
either monetarily
or emotionally so i took three steps
first i called out all the books i
hadn't used in a year
and didn't see myself using in the next
year then
i used an app to scan a barcode of those
books to see if any of them had resale
value
i sold those books and made about 200
last i took the remaining books and
posted them a few at a time to my
instagram story as a free giveaway
i offered to do a drop off to anyone
local or ship the media mail to anyone
else
the response was amazing and seeing all
the joy that my used books were bringing
to others
made it totally worth the small sadness
that i felt
when i was giving them away all right
y'all thanks again to meg nordman for
joining us today
the book is have yourself a minimalist
christmas you can check it out on
audiobook or print or
ebook i'm assuming uh where else can
they find you online meg
yeah you can find me at meg nordman
pretty much everywhere meg nordman
on all social media twitter instagram
facebook
pinterest you name it and megnordman.com
i have links to the book there it's on
amazon it's available on audiobook
print e-book pretty much everywhere
books are sold well you're gonna be
joining us for the maximal episode
here shortly for our added value segment
this week
ryan yes our friend tk coleman
i can't do what he does so we have a
friend t.k coleman he's been on the
podcast
six or seven eight times now he's been
on the podcast more than anyone else we
love him he's
in many ways the third minimalist um and
he uh every day of the year listens to
christmas music
yeah uh every day of the year his
reasoning is because he just yeah he
just loves
the cheeriness of it so it's like what
was he saying he's like try to listen
to have yourself a merry little
christmas and not be in a good mood
now i i had an aversion to this for a
long time i don't know if you remember
this ryan i was managing a few retail
stores i
had just hired you at the company we're
working at and our westchester store
had muzak but it still ran on the discs
oh yeah
and the westchester store west chester
ohio
it the discs got stuck in there and it
was a christmas disc
and so it just kept playing christmas
songs
for months wow after christmas and i
don't know there was something about
that
there's something about not being able
to change the music that all of a sudden
makes it torturous
yeah well yeah well you know the order
of the songs that's what got me
it was like i knew that okay this is
silent night now jingle bells is gonna
be next
and yeah i mean that was the uh there
was no anticipation
did you ever watch uh black mirror
there's they did this episode called
white christmas
i don't know if you remember that one i
mean i've seen them all but yeah i don't
remember that particular one yeah so at
the very
end this guy's sort of trapped in this
house and the
christmas music he's he's in a
simulation but like
um he is trapped in this house and
christmas music is playing
and he can't turn it off every time he
breaks the radio it reappears
that's kind of how i how i felt uh
anyway
i don't want you to feel that way uh
since it is december now is the
perfect time to start playing christmas
music right i think now is the
appropriate time so i mean
it's it's uh fall right now as we're
recording this yeah and i listened to
vince graldy's charlie brown christmas
this morning
before walking to the studio to get in
the zone
but i actually listen to vince graldy
every time i write oh wow
even if it and you know pandora or
youtube will slip in
you know charlie brown christmas and
it's just so happy this little jazz trio
that i
think of christmas yeah so yeah well so
for our writing flow
yeah for added value this week um you
know i've been recommending pandora for
whatever reason lately i think you're so
cool
i think it's the minimalist most
minimalist music episode it takes away
my choices
yeah you know and so i i do the ad free
version
you can do whatever you want i just
don't like having ads online so i think
it's four or five bucks a month
uh but on there i i listen to every
year we have just called christmas radio
it's like their official christmas radio
station you can play it all year round
obviously
but for december we turn on in the house
like all the time
yeah basically starting around
thanksgiving until
christmas and it does no even even when
you're in california or
florida you're still able to set the
sort of christmas mood it's not the same
thing as maybe being in ohio with snow
and everything else
but man it it really does it puts you in
it immerses you into the holiday season
so yeah
added value christmas radio on pandora
all
month long pandora for me is sort of
this experiment and letting go of
control because no longer am i like
i'm gonna pick the songs and it's
michael buble on the playlist
and it's going to be you know frank
sinatra or whoever they have a classic
christmas one too which is what i listen
to
okay nice so it's more bing crosby frank
sinatra yeah
if you want that rather than the mariah
carey type stuff maroon 5 christmas yeah
well check it out we'll put a link to
that in the show notes and real quick
for right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalist you know we wrote a book a
few years ago
it was an essay collection called
essential it's 12
areas of intentional living one of those
areas there's a whole chapter in there
on gift giving
and so if you want an additional
resource in addition to have yourself a
minimalist christmas then
you can check out our book essential
it's our longest book if you want the if
you like our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version it's over six
hours long uh it's called essential
essays by
the minimalist 150 different essays
about intentional living in there
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist come to one of our live
podcast
shows visit the minimalist.com tour to
find a city near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo
to podcasts at theminimalists.com you
can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive our
simple sunday emails whenever we send
those
and if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
bye